attends le serpent le serpent à ont des
martyrs et si vous êtes je fais pas dans
trop de vidéos et tout bois bat
peut-être chose auquel nous devons tous
partout sur tout ce qu'on voit avec
régurgiter c'est situe la manipule trop
savourer la bonne ambiance faite des
serpents après avoir mangé es-tu les
veines plus pendant quelques jours et
prend entière dans cette gestion à
quelques jours donc tu vas pas la
manipuler c'est comme si tu vois je
faisais mon bien énorme magnum et que
derrière j'étais bien à faire du
trampoline sur marche ça sur le venin de
cette espèce est vraiment pas très
dangereux
salut tanguy saluer cyrus bienvenue dans
ce nouvel épisode de t'imaginer team et
merci beaucoup merci de cet accueil chez
moi ça fait très plaisir rôles et je
vais chez moi ce que faisait pas trop
voir mais il ya des on est entouré
d'aquarium et les terrasses voulez en
voir plus vous invite à avoir la chine
et hong kong étaient présentes éviter un
bonjour à tous je m'appelle tanguy j'ai
entre autres dans ma vie plusieurs
façons mais la plus grande passion de
gestion des animaux et j'en ai fait mon
bilan n'est pas dit tu vois clairement
c'est vrai c'est au lycée et c'est vrai
que quand une hausse est bien aussi
relevé que je peux pas blairer gênait
c'était la moto mais le nom et on reste
way sur vraiment de l'animalier de
l'animalier il ya plein de trucs que
j'ai aussi mais en tout cas c'est là
dessus que je communique via la chaîne
youtube donc qui est devenu un peu mon
bas mon métier en fait sur mesure des
années et donc aujourd'hui je dit ça et
j'ai une chaîne soit aux animaux je fais
des tutos développe plein de cash c'est
à dire un truc
les abonnés cyrus syrie je l'aï emmené
faire un petit atelier dé
sensibilisation sur les serpents il ya
quelques semaines j'en ai fait une vidéo
pour le lancement de la vidéo en
descriptions dallas mais en tout cas je
dois dire que c'est bluffant parce que
j'ai connu cyrus avant l'atelier des
sensibilisations et après et avant bas
là il aurait jamais été aussi à l'aise
avec cette couleuvre donc je suis hyper
content d'être là la bouffe est
bouillant mais en vrai tu es en mode
comme si on caresser un chien quoi tu
vois ta richardson a plus du tout
crainte tu vois tu te méfies plus utile
sans faire un avec l'animal bah écoute
alors reste tranquille quand même voilà
mes mais en tout cas ça se passe bien en
arrière comme ali khan et ou quoi oui
moi je suis vraiment s appelle l appât
nom à la longue allée là bas non
aujourd'hui la question à laquelle on va
répondre enfin que les gens
on répondait pas sinon on lit les
réponses des jambes tension c'est
imagine si les animaux pouvaient parler
trop cool je trouve le sujet du parcours
[Musique]
on commence la parole implique une
certaine intelligence donc les animaux
sur des des citoyens au même titre que
nous la zoophilie ne serait plus mal vu
en revanche le quart à nice ne serait
assimilé à du cannibalisme
c'est mal vu le son fils non c'est cool
parce que du coup j'ai apprend des trucs
père après sa queue on pense pas
forcément un truc de thé on imagine fort
cisaillement pouvaient parler ils
auraient le même statut alors qu'en fait
défection ce qu'ils pouvaient parler
ouais c'est vrai paul doucet qui créent
des droits des règles alors c'est clair
bien sûr parce qu ils se diraient pas
bon mais là je suis bien tranquille tu
m'en remets à l'abattoir cool j'ai hâte
j'ai très hâte d'être découpés sympa non
je pense qu'il ya un syndicat de bâches
complètement qui voilà c'est fini
j'espère que les végétaux jamais se
mettre à parler puisque si abba là ça
deviendrait costa mon bordel est en fait
ce qui sera marrante c'est de se dire
que si les végétaux et les animaux
avaient le pouvoir
est ce que le jugement serait toujours
aux tubes sur tubes tels qu'ils auront
une organisation qui ferait qu'en fait
nous on passe pour des mecs totalement
ariary et c'est nous qui serions en bas
de l'échelle en temps de dire genre si
les animaux parlent eh ouais peut-être
que en fait il nous mettrait la pâtée ah
ben moi je pense qu'ils passeront au
dessus parce que tu vois l'animal c'est
une destruction d'écosystèmes
il a une gestion plus tôt durable de ce
qu'ils consomment et polluent pas donc
clairement si l'animal qui parle et qui
prend le pouvoir au dessus et nous on
serait là roi ou en fait c'est où
l'exemple le truc c'est que avec la
parole enfin malgré la parole on est un
machin on a tellement 1 qu' une sorte de
puissantes tu as même s'il parlait je
pense qu'on pourrait les dominés n'ont
mis sur la bourre mais en vrai
sincèrement moi que tu as eu la chance
de goûter les pales de bestioles que
j'ai côtoyé un moment de ma vie quelques
conseils nous aurons le temps et comme
certains animaux qui sont vraiment déjà
tellement a dit vivre en paix des singes
ouais en fait ça va déjà les premiers
trucs pour aller faire des recherches
qu'on a les premières preuves de culte
chez les animaux qui sont des chimpanzés
qui en afrique je crois que c'est beau
mais je ne suis pas sûr mais d'être
calmes trappe en fait il m'a des caméras
la forêt 3 et dès que le chimpanzé base
de bambou une sas ma fille
en fait si on trouvait des mouvements
super chaude ou autour d'un arbre qu'ils
ont eu plein de caméras autour de cet
arbre un fait sont rendus compte que les
chimpanzés amener des offrandes à cet
art les primatologues mais aussi les
sociologues tout dire on en fait c'est
les prémices d'un culte à dire qu'en
gros il voit dans cet art quelque chose
et apporte une offrande pense que c'est
une fiction décalage en fait c'est que
nous on en avance mais que laissent leur
butin les senneurs des centaines de
milliers d'années et tu verras si on
pouvait parler avec les animaux on
serait sans doute plus à l'écouté de
leurs besoins il y aurait aussi plus de
lois qui les protègerait on pourrait
plus en manger il aurait peut-être le
droit à une sécu une justice ça voudrait
dire que tous les emplois dans le
secteur de la viande et disparaîtrait
les abattoirs les eaux les boucheries et
les exploitations d'élevage 2 me mais
d'autres seraient créés on pourrait
imaginer qu'à l'instar des juges et
avocats pour mineurs il y aurait pour
les animaux il y aura aussi probablement
des psy pour chien
bah déjà ça existe en fait exception
charest ouais y'a on n'a plus un
comportementaliste donc bosser un veto
de l'esprit d'animal sur un groupe
breton chien noir qu'est ce qu'il a fait
aita fait caca dessus sus
voilà et marcy les animaux pouvaient
parler ils te dirai je te hommes et en
plus il a fait une très belle mère d'un
magnifique
bon on va nettoyer tout ça bave c'est le
genre de truc tu vois on ne peut pas le
président en exercie je m'étais dit il
faut absolument que ce faire pencher sur
ce terme est cependant une 16 puis
emploi ouais ça pue fort en plus alors
tu sais quoi on va faire un petit clean
tu vois et on va reviendra très vite on
vacciner un peu
je suis choqué je suis dégouté je suis
malheureux vaincu voir trouvera
notamment
c'est parti c'est parti mon kiki
ok nous revois ces géants sont dedans
c'est du propre
tu vois le à voir il nous reste que
l'odeur on a vu on a pu être à le choc
ouais donc en vérité sur les piscines
les chiens les pouilles les psy pour
chien ouais donc voilà ça c'est bien sûr
sa belle un comportementaliste c'est par
exemple pour chien il fait des trucs qui
partent on couche chez toi même à se
mettre des trucs ton canapé bas se
mettra pas supporté d'être tout seul
bah il est pas malade il est malade de
l'esprit cieux donc tu vas aller voir un
veto qui va essayer de comprendre ce qui
se passe comment ton chien et le
rapporteur avec mon chien ce que
contient le droit de faire pas le droit
de faire très vite on va identifier le
problème qui fait que ton chien balle
exprime en détruisant plus laurent qui
s'empare tout voilà ça se règle et c'est
ouais franchement dans 99% des cas ça se
règle très très bien et qui s'est même
des chiens qui sont dans des états loin
quoi des chefs ont déjà mordu des
humains qui sont vraiment dans tsahal
marc et où tu l'aimés dans un bon cadre
et que c'est une bonne personne qui
reprend peut arriver à des résultats
incroyables très vite quoi j'ai des
histoires de chirac et maman
on aurait emmené surpiqué parce qu'un
genre en design hyper dangereux et si
aujourd'hui les super jeunes familles le
reste la question ce n'est pas déjà
utilisé qui auraient des tribunaux pour
animaux donc ça c'est pareil ils ont des
droits
les gars donc aujourd'hui t'as pas le
droit de battre un animal aura de faire
des sévices est un animal tamura de
maltraité un animal et du bal en prison
ça me souviens des affaires qui avaient
soit pas un mec sur ce n'a pas l'abruti
qui avait jeté un chat contre un mur non
non non non exactes à deux ou trois ans
mais elle a pris de faire marcher plus
combien me la plus ferme et en vrai tant
mieux moi tu vas super chevronnés ça
déjà sans prendre un animal c'est chelou
mais en plus de ces nappes et les mêmes
familles de filtres opus qui seront donc
le chat le court je me désolidarise de
7,5 sur la viande
ouais mais alors ça j'ai pas compris les
lire parce que ton animal il parle mais
devant lyon il tient pas vegan cenovus
qui parle qui se dit à bout vas-y ces
bonbons à la viande en fait comme j'ai
pris la parole mon truc c'est brocoli et
accises animaux parlait il y aurait
quand même des problèmes c'est avec les
syndicats de l'avhc dirais oui doucement
les violets acompte novation de nos
semblables parce que vous êtes en train
de mettre à mal notre population
on dirait mais nous on a besoin de vous
les vaches parce que voilà autant nous
on est au niveau on peut manger tout le
lion nom qui les carnivores
si les animaux peuvent parler leur
intelligence sera impacté de manière
fulgurante il pourrait apprendre les
mathématiques la poésie la philosophie
et tous les domaines jusqu'à présent
resté à l'homme
au final la parole et la communication
va de pair avec la réflexion et si ces
animaux peuvent réfléchir autrement que
par des instincts primaires la
différence entre l'intelligence humaine
mal serait extrêmement faible voire
inexistante inexistante ce qui mènerait
je suppose à une guerre mondiale un
terreau espèce de truc de guerre inter
espèces si on pourra jamais battu
laisserait la place à un lapin tu
laisseras il ya une partie de ton jardin
ou la pas parce qu'il dit ouais mais moi
aussi je suis chez moi et tu penses que
j'en les espèces vont prendre le pas sur
dans le fait qu'on soit tous humains par
exemple c'est plus fort comme lien que
le fait que auch pas moi soit tout ce
carnivore georgina ouais tu veux dire
ouais je pense que la fraternité intra
israël sait plus que moi je veux rester
debout à foils simule de ghouat je pense
comme toi je te dis ça mais je sais pas
parce que tu vois aujourd'hui tu vois
dès maintenant ce sont les chiffres qui
sont avec les dom ouais ouais les chiens
axial est annulée diala tout ce qu'est
sauvage nous en reste avec les humeurs
de la ligue domestique et on prend pas
de risque quoi tout ce qui est tribunal
de lyon le machin des tigres on n'y va
pas à oui c'est clair par contre oui la
torche trouve c'est quand il dit qu les
animaux fera débat thématique ça nous
font déjà des mathématiques tu voudras
singe par exemple tu vois et quand la
notion de quoi avoir des notions de
conté il ya déjà des animaux qui parlent
mais alors ça je te garde elle à la
carte
barresi mec sort tu as plein d'animaux à
qui on communique via un outil je te
prends un exemple coco coco c'est un
gorille qui est décédé il ya pas très
longtemps avec les greens langues et y
voilà elle avait la langue des signes
parfaite elle connaissait je crois je
passe dans le cône rim 200 signe tu vois
donc elles communiquent et parfaitement
elle transmettait ses émotions qui
relient signe donc un moment qu à la
bande annonce assez une contre
indication intéresse pas si c'est entre
les gorilles et l'essayer non centre
gorilles et les jours je n'avais pas je
n'arrive pas je me dis merde il a brigué
qu'est ce qui l'a aidé 1 cuil
l'oiseau est arrivé ok si les animaux
parler notre langue
on vivrait dans un bois les chants des
oiseaux au matin alors s'imaginer siat
images y en a déjà qui supporte pas les
oies des chants des oiseaux du matin
alors t'imagines si tu les entends des
raconté
wesh la maison j'ai des français le clu
horaire c'est vrai que ce serait galerie
quand tu passes région soit trop goûté
tu marches avec les chiens étaient dans
la rue est vrai boost
c'est une vanne de spoils caps regrets
cl vous pouvez parler on les humanise
ray plus et il pourrait vraiment être
nos potes et pas inférieur comme des
animaux domestiques ya un truc
diana non mais inférieurs comme des
animaux domestiques parce que l'animal
domestique il est plus d'un fork animal
sauvage ah oui parce qu'il est je pense
qu'ils font ce qu'ils oublient par des
mois est en cours spot about me pose la
question parce que bayonne c'est pas
cool pense que si tu es une poule en
batterie par exemple été élevé par un
humain et tu sert juste à pondre des
oeufs dans le noir et qu'on s'occupe pas
bien de toi et que tu as vraiment une
condition de vie atroces s'éclater
carrément a suivi et c'est vraiment pas
cool
après tu vois je conserve mon chien à
date là on pressent avis c'est
donnant-donnant c'est à dire que l ai vu
super cool elle ne supporte où tu vois
elle mange allemange bien mais est là il
a l'oeil ravi tient bien le voit plein
d'autres chiens puis jamais vénéra avec
elle après duo kool on s'entend bien
donc je me dis que les pas assouvi tu
vois je ne vois pas comme des esclaves
du tout quoi
des anecdotes style à garder ça mais non
super chien a dit que la salle en bas
voilà allait sceller le smac de trop
aller des dieux j'adore ma chaîne mais
je fais pas dès ce match dégueulasse à
t'imaginer si les animaux pouvaient
parler ils auraient alors un cerveau
très développé et il serait capable de
renverser la domination d une entre le
monde qui jugerait trop néfaste pour
leur propre vie et pour la planète
extermination des humains soient donc
l'objectif principal ou alors une
répartition de la planète entre les
humains et les animaux se veut être
envisagée avoue-t-il et souvent de
coopèrent si l'humain ne serait pas
coopérer nous ferons tout pour nous
mettre à bout et nous supprimer les
chiens nous aiderons t-il
car je connais beaucoup moins bien les
animaux toi mais s'il y avait une guerre
de mots entre les humains et les animaux
qui gagnent des fonds et il n'y a pas
besoin de guerre ou des fonds déjà en
fait tu vois tu vois je non mais c'est
vrai mais mec c'est la vérité quoi tu
vois j'entendais encore il ya deux
semaines que 60 % des espèces d'animaux
sauvages ont été décimées sur terre il
reste que à peu près 10% des stocks de
requins il reste que hier je disais
qu'il restait 20 % des stocks de thon
tout le monde nous dit on tout bouffer
des sushis les japonais depuis toujours
nous depuis quelques dizaines d'années
et pourtant pas
plus tard il va avoir ton menu yakitori
pour 12 bal avec des sushis et touche
isolé ton sauvage sao sûrement plus que
ça en fait à la fin c'est à dire que en
plus tu mets ça au capitalisme où on
veut tous pas cher non mais énormément
la pression sur une espèce un ton ça va
se reproduire il va lui falloir schéma
peut-être 7 8 9 10 ans on pourra se
reproduire
on leur laisse pas le temps en plus tu
vois donc on va décimer totalement
quelque chose pour notre qui fera les
coûts de l'ambiance de cette image inc
non mais c'est bien parce que ouais mais
si les gens se rendent pas compte en
fait que quand tu bouffes 1
c'est vrai moi ça m'empêche pas d'en
bouffer mais à chaque fois je n'ai pas
vu de l'histoire donc si bas c'est bien
c'est bien mais il ya des choses sur
lesquelles je peux plus tu vois j'ai
arrêté à viande rouge cuite foie gras
parce que c'est trop de torture le ton
je bouffe pas de thon rouge donc c'est
aussi en prenant conscience de tout ça
qui change les comportements tous les
tons rouges lors du bordeaux rose pas
arrêter quoi je vais le ton j'évite quoi
c'est qu'on le tout les camaïeux où tu
vois si roman nuancent-ils shermont
murcie à temps et j'y touche plus le
poids si les animaux pouvaient parler le
perroquet serait juste des deux matchs
alors à jeu à leur âge
ouais parce que la couleur c'est joyeux
c'est nul mais c'est trop beau libero
griffi c'est magique donc ces rageux de
taille mais les perroquets si les
animaux pouvaient parler notre langue
notre vision du monde sera transformée à
force de côtoyer d'autres espèces
peut-être que les hommes c'est nîmes
analyserait par exemple la violence sera
moins tabou puisque tout le monde
entendre et son chat qui fait dégommer
les mieux choisis on serait tous
traumatisés au début et on les entend
s'envoyer en l'air les ça finirait par
ne contamine et peut-être même qu'on
finira dans une société apocalyptique
avec zéro barrières sociales ou alors ça
changerait rien à part que tout le monde
deviendrait vegan et qu'on sauvera la
planète
c'est drôle c'est maria des mages et que
c'est nous qui nous anime à doha et qui
sont pourrait être influencée j'avoue et
saint-trond via des chats qui ne ferait
jamais il y avait jamais pisser sur des
faits pour marquer avec toi bien chier
autres alertes à un poteau l'astroballe
que tu lui fais la bise sur l'île tudy
wright
c'est comme ça quand tu dis bonjour
merde je veux dire bon pour demain où
les bonobos qui me dira non baez ah bah
non en baisse ouais vous faites des
colloques sur le chemin qui mène
maintenant les pv en fait comment nous
on baisse un peu quand il ya un conflit
on a trouvé la semaine sur direct donc
la baisse malgré même si ça va bien on
baise
notre projet c'est ce à quoi on pouvait
parler aux animaux ce serait très chiant
car on entendrait h 24 les acariens sont
notre peau discuter entre elles et bien
c'était un truc à dire aux animaux
serait quoi cheveux longs et je pense
que s'il avait un truc à nous dire ce
serait quoi genre synopsis mettait tous
d'accord qu on dirait un truc sérieux
tanguy c'est un plaisir c'est vrai brown
et a pas du tout trop parlé il ya
quelqu'un a t'il bien trop bien je me
souviens de la version bêta les en à ma
fille oui mais il a testé avec les
petits papiers dans le petit temps de
l'été là-haut phase de test quelqu'un
qui l'a gagné c'est vrai ouais cool
c'est la gagne et son prénom sa fille
pour le prochain épisode la question à
laquelle vous avez à répondre en
commentaire c'est imagine si on était
tous des x men
c'est à dire tu imagines si on essaie
tous avec un super pouvoir qu'on ne
choisissait pas et pour cet épisode je
serai accompagné de tom que vous avez
déjà vu sur cette chaîne les cool cool
ça marche bien non mais ça marche bien
j'ai été content safran c'est trop bien
moi j'ai sorti en triple kay aqua ya un
gros mois un petit bouquin sur l'élevage
d'animaux
je vous conseille cissé inspirational si
tu ne sais en vie d'animaux mais tu ne
sais pas quoi acheter et ben écoute adam
tu auras 39 choix possibles sur des
animaux ils ont tous pour point commun
d'être facile ils sont totalement
c'est ce que c'est le point commun de
ces deux truc c'est que sa défense c'est
que ça défonce et que c'est un super
cadeau pour noël on se retrouve avec ce
temps guy soit la semaine prochaine soit
dans deux semaines en thaïlande
ouais c'était cool c'est un nouveau
tournage et j'ai laissé j'ai gardé la
tient pour l'heure fait un petit teaser
pas regardé j'ai un souvenir de ce
tournage ça c'est ses films et voilà et
ça c'est un souvenir du tournage vers
est une vraie ce qui attriste un format
qui sera très différent de ce que je
fais d'habitude sur la chaîne j'espère
que ça m'a fait marrer et c'est je pense
qu'il ya moyen de voir des choses
intéressantes c'est quelque chose qu'on
voit pas d'habitude dans divers
circulent
franchement que gt gt les symboles
j'étais hyper content que tu me
reçoivent chez moi ça m'a fait quand
même plus hyper président hu est super
contents super format super cool très
mon niveau de questions la première je
voudrais la première j'étais vraiment
away [ __ ] j'avoue ça changerait tout
trop cool hyper cool bravo et je trouve
ça mène à plein de réflexions et tous et
gens mais tu imagines si un jour je
revenais bon temps abonnez-vous à la
chaîne de drogués si vous connaissez pas
la piste ça les amis ciao
[Musique]